the elves are at a bit of a connection
to Kelly Clarkson because they had their
babies just two days apart back in April
and today we got in a chat with Kelly
for the first time about her new
addition to the family he's five months
and he's um he's just chill he loves
anything he loves to be entertained by
his sister that's why we had them so
close together plenty with each other
yeah yeah mommy has a glass of wine
transfer more no shirt no oh you're not
at all things have been taken out so
that cannot happen we're done Kel he's
definitely got a full house she's mom to
daughter
rivero's and son Remy with husband
Brandon Blackstock and she's stepmom to
brandon's two kids but it's her
two-year-old river he's keeping her on
her toes she's sweet but she is
definitely in her terrible twos how has
being a mom changed your life I'm like
way more confident way more empowered
way more like I've got this then I
realized my husband has to reel me in a
lot so we're definitely a team yeah I'm
sure yeah I'll be like fine fine fine
that I'm like Kelly Clarkson the girl
who won American Idol back in 2002 is on
tour again
but this time as a children's author
promoting her first ever picture book
River rose and the magical lullaby it
wasn't like something that I was like I
want to do this and we started from
scratch I actually did this for my
daughter like I wrote little stories for
her and you're writing new music now
which we are all really excited about
the album I've been dying to make since
I was looking junior high you single
when is that dropping it's next year if
any of your four children came up to you
and said you know mom I want to go
audition what would you say
song selection is key it's just a hard
job a lot of times if they want to do it
yeah like I said whatever but it's
always hard especially good famous mom
that's gonna suck